hi everyone I'm Alana I'm just about to
play in halo 2 anniversary which is part
of the master chief collection here at
Gamescom let's take a look
Oh
so i guess i'm going to stop by saying
that the line halo 2 anniversary or the
remaster ii of halo 2 at Gamescom was
really big all the time
I particularly loved in Halo 2 that
there's a button like halo anniversary
for the first one that you can just swap
between the old graphics and the new
graphics in like a second but it also
stops between the sound so if you press
that button all of the sounds from the
original there and then you press it
again it swaps back and there are new
upgraded sounds there's also a new
engine designed specifically for the
Xbox one new graphics updates which
includes weapons and maps with new
textures there's new UI and fully
remastered maps with some really really
familiar gameplay
you
the ranking system is apparently exactly
the same as the original hello to online
which is awesome to hear there's also
going to be forged a halo 2 anniversary
which is really really cool to see
it's going to be coming out with the
full master chief collection which also
contains halo 4 halo 3 and Halo one
anniversary and I feel like this is
going to cause a whole new wave for halo
right I don't know what people play
online anymore I spent most of my time
playing reach online in terms of halo
but I feel like I'm going to be spending
a lot of time and halo 2 multiplayer and
it wouldn't surprise me if the rest of
the world does something similar
unfortunately I guess that's all I
really have to say about that it's it's
halo 2 but prettier and I'm happy about
that so Halo fans will probably be just
as happy you definitely have a lot to
look forward to hear